when you're the lawyer in a time to kill
and you're doing that summation to the
jury
and you're asking them not to convict
this black man who's killed some white
people
i want to tell you a story
i'm gonna ask you all to close your eyes
i'll tell you this story
i want you to listen to me i want you to
listen to yourselves do you go to court
to find a lawyer you can emulate
no no no how do you know how to do that
something like that i've done
biographies where i'll go study the real
person
or play a person with the vocation an
astronaut cooper and interstellar i've
got to go learn
sort of what that arena is and and how
their mind works and astronauts mind
works
as far as jake brigance is a lawyer and
a time to kill
i was very comfortable and i wanted to
be a lawyer all my life anyway i'm
sitting there thinking
okay i don't have children but what if
this was my daughter
that's i'm making it very personal in
that moment trying to think what if it's
my daughter
and then to the jury can you understand
at the end that's the flip now imagine
she's white to an all-white jury now
imagine if it's your
daughter get them there
and you know when acting when acting is
going well for the best for me
i see the picture in my mind then just
say and tell you what i see
and that becomes the conversation it's a
great summation it's a great movie
moment i cried during that man that was
awesome
i mean you brought me you know he just
wrote another book the sort of the
sequel there was sycamore row and now
there was time for mercy grisham just
wrote the new book
and it's good it's good it's been
brought up to me quite a few times hey
would you go back and
be jake bergans again i gotta say it was
fun reading it and i could not help but
think read it and read jake's role and
go oh
how interesting would that be to be back
in those shoes play jake brigance this
many years later in another case
on the other side if time to kill is
what it was and now he wrote time for
mercy
could be tasty isn't it true that
grisham
um originally they wanted woody
harrelson for your role in a time to
kill
somebody said no to woody harrelson
because
he played molly in in natural-born
killers
around that time there was a man in
mississippi that got murdered by
two kids that were acting out the mickey
and mallory characters from
natural one killers but that and i was
told was a reason
woody did not get approved do you call
up woody at night go
woody you [ __ ] lost the best roll of
your life to me and then hang up the
phone
you ever do that i would do that yeah
right i mean
yeah that i do i do leave him messages
like
absolutely
you